the fight got announced and it's just
honing in on on what I've done my whole
life to get me here
UFC star Jorge masvidol gearing up to
hit the ring in Miami on Saturday I'm
very confident in my takedown defense
because it's it's dramatically improving
the last span of eight months and that's
because I I put a lot of distractions
aside and I just focus on one thing
getting better at wrestling I didn't
throw a punch for a long time I didn't
throw a knee I didn't do anything but
just rush on the morning wrestle at
night he's set to go head-to-head
against Gilbert Burns and the
welterweight bout this man has a cult
following and then some he has put Miami
on the map at this point in my career I
truly feel that I am one of the best in
the world if not the best at
welterweight in this fight with Gilbert
here in Miami is everything since I
signed up for the sport was to fight the
best in the world and to grab titles not
for nothing else and to make the most
money possible I have a job to do and
that's compete whether it's here in
Pluto it's a fight at the end of the day
so it's just get after man it's just
another fight if it was right here it
was in the KFC parking lot or the UMC
Arena just get after
and this fight is going to have some
special guests in the crowd Jorge's
three children my kids will be in
attendance for this fight cheering their
dad I'm watching you know the reason why
they have all the great opportunities in
life now is because of these things
right here their dad is uh is a
hard-working man that you know not to
play the victim role but it ain't
growing up and I went and got it with
these bad boys right here so I'd love to
lay that example in the flesh to my kids
for them to see not that I ever wanted
to fight but if you want something you
better put your mind to it and get after
it and when it comes to dating tell you
the truth man with my lifestyle you know
I fight I'm at the gym all day I run a
couple different promotions I have two
MMA promotions that I own in a boxing
promotion that I own so between fighting
promoting training and Recovery it's not
about like what they have it's they got
to put up with my ass and all my crazy
demands and what I say and she got to be
able to cook she gotta be able to dance
you gotta be able to clean She Gotta
Have Fitness She Gotta Have a brains on
her but for Jorge he's not worried about
winning anyone one over sending this
message to his haters yeah I still love
you man and um you can come jump back on
this bandwagon if you want or not it
doesn't matter I never did it for haters
lovers anything I did it for me my
family my kids is a way out so I I never
I never take a person with people
cheering me for not this is a free ass
country and
um you had to base all your opinions on
whatever you want so me it's just like
do my job you know the more haters I got
meetings are probably doing something
right for his fans they can catch him
face off against Gilbert Saturday April
8th on ESPN plus when I defeat Gilbert
Burns um we're gonna spill out to the
streets for all of Miami that you know
the Miami and you know it's going to be
popping till like six in the morning I'm
gonna eat a lot of my Latin food and I'm
going to be celebrating
thank you